in the not so distant future you'll
likely be writing far fewer lines of
code than you are today
because artificial intelligence is
coming to a vs code near you
microsoft aka github just announced
copilot yesterday
a tool powered by gpt3 capable of
writing code automatically
all you have to do is write a
descriptive function name or some
comments
and it will automatically fill in the
implementation details for you
and it's not just inserting a snippet
this is actual novel code
that has never been seen before it looks
at the code you've already written in
your project as
context and attempts to generate new
code to match it perfectly
for example imagine you've written a
react component and you now want to
write a unit test for it
just write a comment describing what you
want to test and copilot will generate
the code based on your component
and the testing framework that you're
using or say you want to calculate the
number of days between two dates for me
that's an instant google search then
stack overflow copy and paste
with copilot all i have to do is write a
function name and it implements the
function body for me automatically if
i'm not perfectly happy with the
implementation
i can click a button to get the next
prediction anything that might have
brought you to stack overflow can be
autocompleted in your ide
and custom tailored to fit your code
base developers like to joke about how
often they google things and copy
answers from stack overflow
so you can only imagine how big of a
time saver this is going to be
i just got access to copilot myself so
let's dive in and see how useful it
really is
i just installed the extension and bs
code which required me to authenticate
with my github account i've got a
front-end vanilla javascript project
here
with files for my html css and
javascript you'll notice a little
copilot icon down here at the bottom
that just allows you to toggle it on or
off the first thing i want to try
is to define a function called
intersection of arrays
and see if it can complete the body of
that function successfully
we'll give the function a name of
intersection of o and it just predicts
the name of the function that we're
going to write and it looks like it's
being implemented correctly
but there are multiple ways we could
implement this function let's go ahead
and delete the code back to the function
name
if we hover over the automatically
generated code we can click next
to cycle through different suggestions i
actually don't see any i like here so
i'm going to click the open copilot
option
that will synthesize 10 different
possible solutions and it happens very
fast like within one or two seconds
but looking closer at the solutions it
looks like they are all pretty much the
same
even though i know there are multiple
different approaches to implementing an
intersection of arrays the top answer on
stack overflow actually has a cleaner
implementation
and i would have expected this to at
least be an option in the results but
let's move on
and see if we can build a little counter
app that has multiple moving parts
first i'm going to define some state
which is just a variable equal to zero
you'll notice that it's trying to make
predictions as i'm writing out this
variable that is one thing that's kind
of annoying it's almost a little too
aggressive when making predictions
it would be nice if the ai could predict
when i actually want predictions
also it predicts things for react and
view even though i'm not in a reactor
view project
in any case the next thing i want to do
here is grab a button from the dom i'll
give the ai a hint by writing a comment
and you'll notice that it actually
auto-completes the comment for me it
knows exactly what i want to do because
it's such a common thing to do
now that we have a button let's set up
an event listener on the click event
to increment the state each time that
it's clicked now i start writing another
comment i don't even type anything
and it fills out that entire comment for
me that's pretty crazy because it's
using the context of our previous line
of code to figure out what to write
next i'll hit tab a couple times and
you'll notice that it sets up an event
listener on the button variable that we
defined then it proceeds to update the
state by incrementing it by 1.
it also adds a modulus 3 here i'm not
sure what that's about that'll just make
it count to three in a loop and i have
no idea where it would get the idea to
do that and finally it knows that we
want to show this state in the ui
so it takes our button and sets the
inner html to the current state that's
pretty wild but now i'm going to go into
the html
and add the button to the dom it doesn't
seem to know that my javascript is
looking for a certain button
but if i add a button comment it will
auto-complete with the expected id
and finally let's jump into our css and
give it some style
if i add a comment for a red button with
a blue background it will start
implementing that code line by line
but it's generally more efficient to
just go straight to the copilot and see
the available options here
an interesting side note is that you'll
get different results here each time you
go to the co-pilot
even if the comment is exactly the same
the results are kind of all over the
place but i think it's enough to give
you some starting code to work with
don't expect this thing to be turning
out production grade code just yet
that's not going to happen
until protocol 4 is implemented now if
we go ahead and open our app in the
browser
we should get this blue button and every
time it's clicked it will increment the
state by the modulus of three
all things considered i think copilot
did a pretty good job it feels a little
rough around the edges but it's by far
the best ai coding experience that i've
ever had
but how does this thing actually work
well in order to build useful ai you
need a ton of data
luckily over the last 12 years
developers have graciously donated their
time and code to help other developers
on the internet
while foregoing their copyright to that
content primarily on the website stack
overflow which was just acquired this
month for 1.8 billion dollars
impeccable timing for their founders to
cash out just weeks before a
game-changing existential threat hits
the industry it also takes code from
public open source github repos
now because it's generating unique code
i don't think it has to worry about any
open source licensing requirements
because this data is public microsoft
can freely use it to build their ai
the deep learning model behind the data
is gpt-3 or
generative pre-trained transformer 3
which is easily one of the most
impressive ai products ever developed
people describe it as amazing
humbling and terrifying and it's really
good at being creative
based on some initial context like it
can take a complex article and summarize
it for a second grader or it can take an
idea that you have for an ad
and generate the actual ad copy under
the hood it's just a massive neural
network that's been trained on over 175
billion parameters to put that in
perspective
there are many popular pre-trained
neural networks out there and none of
them have anywhere close
to 1 billion parameters let alone 175
billion
it's developed by a company called
openai that was founded by people like
elon musk sam
altman and other high-profile tech
figures it started in 2015 as a
non-profit
but i think they realized they could
make a shitload of money and converted
to a for-profit company in 2019. now
microsoft doesn't control openai but
they did make a 1 billion
investment in 2019 then in september
2020
they announced they had licensed the
exclusive use of gpt-3
other companies can still use the api
but microsoft is the only company that
can truly take full advantage of the
gpt3 algorithm that means microsoft will
be able to build products that nobody
can really compete with unless of course
you can build an algorithm that's better
than gpt3 don't let the name fool you
openai is not open
a better name for it might be something
like windows ai but this is all great
news for developers right ever since
microsoft acquired github the developer
experience has been getting better and
better
you can get your github repos directly
in vs code github actions make
continuous integration super easy and
copilot will just be one more awesome
feature to add to the list
but it makes me wonder why does
microsoft love us developers so much
historically microsoft has not had a
great relationship with developers
just google embrace extend extinguish
modern microsoft has been doing a lot of
embracing
and extending but who knows if they have
any plans for the extinguish step
now i'm just joking around here but
let's imagine that the goal was to
replace developers with ai
programmers are expensive in short
supply and one of the biggest expenses
for any tech company
to replace them you need a four-step
plan step one is to get them to share a
bunch of public information about their
code in step two
we use that code to create a product
that makes developers happier and more
productive the initial version won't be
perfect
but as more and more developers use it
we'll collect more and more data
and reinforce the existing algorithm in
theory the algorithm will get so good
that we'll no longer need programmers
who write code
maybe just technicians who can help
guide the algorithm to the right place
at which point your company can fire its
programmers and pay a bunch of
artificial azure coders by the second
copilot is free for now and only
available through a technical preview
but they do plan to develop it into a
commercial product in the future
aws already has code guru for ml powered
code recommendations so the big players
here are already introducing paid
services that will replace the jobs
normally done by human coders we're
currently on step 3 of the plan
but again i'm just joking around here
this is just a meme channel
i love bill gates and microsoft and if
you think they're motivated by anything
beyond their genuine love for developers
then you must be the kind of person who
thinks two plus two equals four all i
ask is that you hit like and subscribe
to my channel so i can keep you updated
on the latest tools hitting our industry
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one